what was the martial art you would get
out with Krav Maga what did Krav Maga
where's that from
it's it's the Israeli Defense Army way
of fighting it's super intense it's
basically how you kill your opponent
that's quickly as classes be busy busy
people to kill training with someone
from the Israeli Defense Army Wow so did
you get properly good news yeah I was
pretty good I was pretty good I like a
lot of fun can you demonstrate could you
like if I could you break a board can
you be like karate can't abort yeah you
do could you even got moves
yeah like if someone came at me with a
knife or something or had a gun I could
disarm them okay survived attacked you
with a bit of fruit you might get hurt
no seriously would you hurt me bad at it
like will you break my heart
I'll go very slow I'm sick now I think
this is an amusing idea okay okay do you
really promise I swear thank you so you
trust her
you should totally
[Applause]
so if you were gonna stab me with you
really hold a knife like that
no I feel I'm sorry oh wait I'm holding
it wrong I'll disarm you the minute you
start holding it properly so like that
well no okay fine
sure no out should I oldest this is fine
so base no no wait a minute no how do
you like if you're gonna stab me
there you go perfect let's do it again
okay so I'm coming at you yeah then I go
like this I'm doing it slow motion so I
don't hurt you
[Applause]
this is the film we're finally at your
version of Professor X becomes bald up
here do you yes did you shave your head
originally all the years back and go in
there to put a wig on you or something I
shaved it months before I came to the
job just to see what was look like and
just take a nice C and then I turned up
with about two months gross thinking
would shave again and so they they spend
a 17-hour my first of two seventeen our
head extension sessions getting hair
extensions / Wow yeah so I've all the
x-men movies I've either had hair
extensions or a wig but this time proper
proper proper follicly challenged yeah
that's me
stop it it looks good what's the thing
with Patrick Stewart but he was somehow
involved in the shaving he's been
involved since the very beginning yeah
when I went to shave my head I was
shaving it and we thought hey well would
at it why don't we try and FaceTime
Patrick and as we were shaving he said
please back it up and send me some hair
and that's funny
and then we just walked away and if the
hair was in the floor and all that so
turns out that the director did back up
and he he has all my hair at home and a
safe which is kind of creepy witchcraft
well I think I don't know about
yourselves that a lot
a salt-and-pepper my lovely and michael
fassbender you learned some special
skills I believe for this film that's
right as I was saying the parkour
elements so I got to perfect the Rollie
pollie you must have known how to do
Rollie pollie at one time in your life
that you could do not now I'm 53 do a
roly-poly you think you can do a
roly-poly
I have tried that's right it's a head
over heels super that's a problem you
have to do it with me yes you can abuse
in a nursing home it will look like
you've just you've dragged summer has a
bed you're kicking them down
okay exactly you do it first okay you do
it first so basically reminding I'm
gonna end up off the stage oh well you
are you gonna do a let me know so
basically you have to keep your hand I
could never do that
place your forearm down first and then
took your head over the edge
yeah so you forearm yeah and then tuck
your shoulder over and stay on that side
don't go straight down your spine okay
so think about it too much
I just go over this pit here yeah hand
this pit and then just roll okay so I'm
never I won't get over
[Applause]
great superpowers come great superpower
gestures a lot of them are taken so how
how did you come up with you know did
people talk it through with you or did
you just you know I was kind of left to
my own devices but I figured you know
everything looks quiet and balletic and
like a dance so I just integrated the
the twist the doorknob of course that's
my move is I just do this russer X the
the magpie salute that's yours like do
you always me too it's weird when I'm in
a car with somebody and they don't that
well I'm saluting but to myself
sometimes as you do that one and maybe
you do the Jazz have jazz hands meets
constipated stance there is a big jazz
hands off you know yes well it's like
you're like holding a teacup and I'm
like oh really
[Laughter]
did you do a punching game this is her
games I did this game what I just wanted
to protect my drink
she taught is this game I didn't I
brought it you did bring we used to do
it the Hunger Games in like a normal way
because you're bored you know you spend
minimum 12 hours on set so it's like you
know you see the circle you get punched
and on Hunger Games it's normal I
brought it to these psychos and now it's
it's truly truly dangerous did you look
normal
that's terrifying it's like whatever
Channel
James and Michael there was I don't know
if you know this man
but James Michael for some reason they
inspire a lot of fan are curious yeah
curious to see how it evolved it hasn't
evolved a lot we're just for the end of
the year we thought we've got to make a
bit of fan art with James and Michael
but just remind ourselves of the sort of
quality that we're aiming for here are
some examples I think we've shown these
before and this is just a lovely one
just to get you confused married that's
Michael that's James Michael looks like
he's put poison in that cherry you will
notice a theme in the pictures Marion so
there's this James Bible here they are
in funny enough they're on a balcony for
the moment
[Applause]
and then the classic James and Michael
in the kitchen oh yeah
Banco we go for a brownie or a fairy
cake so we Cubans out the audience to
see what scenarios they would like to
see the two of you in so where is Vic
Victoria Godfrey West Joe that's
Victoria look at look at Victoria she's
lovely she's very good necklace she's
got a nice top on this is what she wants
to see this she shut her eyes this is
what I want to see I want to see Michael
entering an airplane toilets and turning
around with the week and James following
behind
that's what she wants to see this is
see and what's your name again Victoria
Victoria and see as you see this and
you've revealed your secret Victoria's
Secret quite often guys are like oh I'd
love to watch two women go on it and all
that kind of stuff and then when I've
said to you every would you like to see
two guys go at neurotic no you but the
trend like it's not actually something
women ever actually want to see but just
won't ever tell me that they actually
want to see two guys go at it
just you two it's not generic okay my
second Frank go out and I don't think
the audience
where's-where's it neo me Higgs oh
there's me Munich's noni me we all shoe
for an idea for some artwork she began
to type and couldn't stop this is all
from her Michael loves to exercise we
know that's true however James likes to
eat cake Michael is getting a little
tired of James being so lazy
he's even starting to get a little fat
some might have besides a sign James up
to a Zumba class James rocks up in the
most ridiculous outfit Michael has ever
seen that's the last time Michael will
ask James to exercise
[Applause]
well there's Matthew now Matthew
thoughts long and hard about this
Matthew would like to see the two of you
like Apes picking and eating fleas off
one another's backs booming of course
where's Peter
in bong there's Peter in bong Peter
would like to see James and Michael on a
tandem bike working together yes yes I
like the gorillas gorillas on the bike
oh yes yes you can pick fleas off each
other on the bike and maybe we were
driving through frog so you can do
gorillas in the mist
[Applause]
we've got a tandem bike so if you bring
in the the green-screen
you will put you on the streets of Paris
okay right if you go over to the bike
okay do you and I think for once James
should be at the back there you go
there is a theme about it you're never
at the back in the fan art okay then
we've talked about this last time I know
hang on where's this why is my company
oh because you put the stove put the
scarves on socks I keep it going fast
right
you see you want to start round
oh there you go lovely love me okay okay
so so can we have a romantic background
now please look at this it's mega erotic
okay and I recycling pretend beside you
don't actually cycle that was a disaster
[Music]